and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review Terminator Salvation
oh my gosh the greatest movie I've ever
seen in my life
so the movie starts by showing the Titan
Terminator Salvation and the people were
like crazy in Vinnitsa to see in the
movie and then it shows the title again
Terminator Salvation and people were
like they told us that two seconds
I think it's clip that they remind
people of movie they come to see I once
thought the Bratz movie what's a
documentary on prostitutes we maybe
woods Josie is this guy called John
Connor
and he's further resistance against the
machines
because apparently machines are taking
over the world poker machines take over
the world when I can't even get my
computer to work right I have a computer
you see this is the unsweet and this is
the larger I don't need my peanuts a New
Yorker I just need to be a little
shorter so there's another guy who used
to be in prison
but they killed him and turn him into a
machine I turned into a machine once it
bored me machine and looking for junk
under because they know how to stop the
evil machines it turns out they just had
to create a gigantic control-alt-delete
that's not how he fix my computer though
I just piss on it so John Connor has to
find Kyle Reese because apparently he's
his father and sure cover is like you
are my father everything like a statue
you know it to be true
doughnuts literally impassive
and to take family to do that you will
really you mean I get to sleep with a
woman
yes it's called operation get you laid
unfortunately you die soon after but I
can live right oh yeah so common reason
the machine-man going to stop the evil
robotics and no covers like what's in
here sixty years old my ass he doesn't
see anything always make use of
computer-generated poetry it's not as
Arnold he must stop being the Governor
of California a specific bastard who's
here dumb again trust to a mere for a
few seconds in a movie that is
dedication to your crap
I struggle for a few seconds in the
movie to so many people day so
contouring the rest of the team destroy
the evil machines sorta because Indians
are like the battle is won but the war
rages on what more you just just drive
their headquarters he should have said
that the battle is over
but we're gonna milk this series for all
it's worth that's how every Terminator
movie end you know in the phrase I'll be
back it's so popular cuz it's always
back but on the hood they like this
movie it's a great food and to the
resume of director Mitch G the only
director sounds I can make downloads
value menu purchase I wasn't McDonald's
value menu purchase once history burger
but unfortunately me to meet people
throw up do they decide to go my castle
my computer I can
commercial hi I'm a box and I'm a PC